The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So for
this last class
exercise we have
this following code.
So we have 46 for USA
gold, 27 for UK gold,
1 for Romanian gold.
We make this variable,
here, Total Gold,
to be the sum of those
three which I believe is 74.
Then we're going to
print total gold.
OK?
Then we're going to increase
the value for Romanian gold
and we're going
to print it again.
So as always, you can just
copy this, pop it into Python,
and run it to test yourself,
but you should do it just
in your mind first.
So notice it print
74 in 74, and that's
because we never
told the program
to calculate the new total.
So we only calculated the
total, way up here on line 5.
If we calculated the
total again down here,
then it would be 74.75 So
let's look at the answers,
hopefully you guys got that.
Perfect, majority
are good to go.
If you didn't get that
please try to review it,
review why it didn't work.